straight ahead
on long crime day the dramatic testimony
as the prosecution medical expert
identifies the moment george floyd dies
that's the moment the life goes out of
his body
dr martin tobin who wrote the book on
breathing and lung function
says george floyd died from low levels
of oxygen
plus an in-depth look at judge peter
cahill
his soothing voice and calm demeanor
during the derek chovan trial
belies a take no-nonsense approach he
doesn't back away from tough decisions
even if those decisions might be
unpopular and what about those pills
found in george floyd's car
and the back of the police vehicle will
that help the defense case
claiming he died of a drug overdose the
tablets contained
methamphetamine and fentanyl and new
developments for the so-called
doomsday cult couple law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everybody to law and prime daily
i'm brian ross in our studios in new
york with brian buckmart on assignment
in minneapolis for the trial of derek
shelvin and of course our colleague
terry austin here as well
another strong showing by the
prosecution with the doctor who wrote
the book about breathing and lung
function
saying george floyd died of a low level
of oxygen
here's brian buckmeyer with the latest
brian
yeah brian ross not only did he write
the book on
breathing generally many people refer to
it as the bible
based on that area of profession he gave
us a lot of interesting facts
as well as the number of 20 25
16 the exact moment he pointed out that
george floyd
died now dr tobin a pulmonologist
from chicago he's volunteered to help
the state he said he's reviewed medical
records
interviews and watched the videos he
provided his opinion of how george floyd
died sir floyd
died from a low level of oxygen
and this caused damage
to his brain that we see and it also
caused
a pea arrhythmia that caused his heart
to stop
so they were forcing his left wrist
up into his chest forcing it in tight
against his chest forcing it high up
and you have to keep in mind that the
opposite side
of this is the street so he was being
squashed
between the two sides then in addition
because
of the knee that was rammed in against
the the left side of his chest sometimes
the knee was down
on the arm or in against the chest
so this would have the same effect so
basically
on the left side of his lung
it was almost like a surgical
pneumonectomy it was
almost to the effect as if a surgeon had
gone in and removed the lung not quite
but
along those lines
and brian there was a powerful moment
where the jurors were told they could
find out for themselves what it was like
to have
their breath cut off
exactly what we heard from the pool
reporter is of the 14 jurors
all of them were very intense and
watching but 11 of the 14 as we're
understanding
started to actually mimic what the
doctor was saying and doing on the stand
by touching parts of their neck and
seeing how it might feel
to have certain pressure put on those
parts of the neck it was an engaging
captivating and very powerful moment
especially
when they were acting it out so much so
that eric nelson had to object
the not really an objectionable thing
but the judge did remind them that they
don't
have to do these actions that they're
merely suggesting that they can
but again they were very engaged taking
lots of notes and they really followed
along with this testimony
and brian as you said that key moment
when the doctor identified
what he said was the precise moment that
george floyd died
it wasn't just that he was able to bring
it down to the second
of 2025-16 but that the video
over and over again was shown because
for most
people we don't see people die on a
regular basis
but this doctor has that expertise and
showed us
seeing is that the changes in his facial
appearance
this becomes crucially important again
in seeing the effects of the low oxygen
at the beginning you can see his
conscious
you can see slight flickering and then
it disappears
so when one second he's alive and one
second he's no longer
is that the flick you can see his eyes
he's conscious
and then you see that he isn't
on cross-examination defense attorney
eric nelson asked the doctor about
how floyd's use of fentanyl could have
impacted the condition of his lungs
in terms of the use of fentanyl in the
hospital setting
surgical setting have you become
familiar with
a what's called wooden chest syndrome
yes
and can you explain for the jury what
wouldn't you think some patients
with fentanyl you'll get an increase in
chest wall stiffness
so the lungs become less elastic
not quite the lungs the chest walls okay
so
that would prevent a chest wall
tight or chest wall rigidity will also
uh decrease the performance of the lungs
it will impede the ability of the lungs
to impact
to expand and terry austin there have
been a lot of moments in this trial that
have been very hard to watch but
in particular the one with the doctor
said the life
left george floyd's body absolutely
brian that was a very difficult moment
what made it so impactful is
we all saw the video and we saw what was
happening to george floyd's body
but until dr tobin explained the exact
moment what was
happening to the head to the eyes to the
breathing
we weren't really sure now we are sure
and dr tobin has
a very special way maybe it's his
charming
you know irish accent but he has a very
special way of breaking down
words to the jury and making it seem
very uncomplicated so i think he was
very impactful and i think that the jury
absolutely responded to what the doctor
was describing and brian buckmeyer let
me ask you about another video where
prosecutors created an animation that
recreated the scene
yeah it's not only that they created the
animation but they explained the
necessity to have the animation
because when you look at the different
videos it's hard to kind of
grasp what all the angles are to truly
be able to dissect what happened
and so he used it not only as a tool to
educate himself
but it was very professorial the way he
educated the
the jury it was like he was teaching a
class that we were all captivated in
all right we're still ahead on law and
crime daily the latest update in the
bizarre case
of the so-called doomsday cult couple
but first an in-depth look at the trial
judge in this case
we'll learn more about judge peter
cahill from some of those
closest to him
well you see him each day presiding of
the trial of derek shivan with his
soothing voice
in calm demeanor but what's behind all
that law and crimes antoinette levy
takes a close look at judge peter cahill
anjanette
brian i spoke with both the chief judge
of the hennepin county district court
and the former public defender about
what judge cahill is like both
inside and outside of the courtroom
good morning everyone we'll proceed with
our next witness each morning
judge peter cahill warmly greets the
jurors you may have noticed some
lighthearted moments with them
go ahead and throw me under the bus with
your fiance but there have also been
times when it was clear cahill was angry
what's your connection to this case and
he didn't hesitate to remind people that
he's in charge
i think what we're getting into is
criticizing each other's performance
let's not do that hennepin county's
chief judge todrick barnett chose cahill
to preside over the cases of derrick
chauvin
and the three other officers this moment
is not too big for him
cahill has been on the bench since 2007
and burnett says he has good control of
the courtroom
and the law he's going to base his
decision on the law
and that decision could be
unpopular with the public
but it's going to be a sound legal
decision
and i think he's done a really good job
with the jurors
former hennepin county public defender
mary moriarty
has appeared in cahill's courtroom when
cameras weren't there
he was a prosecutor he was a public
defender he's very
conversant in criminal law which is
important
he has pretty good temperament that
temperament has been on display for the
world to see
judge cahill making the decision to
allow the trial of derek chovin to be
streamed gavel to gavel
a first in minnesota's history i thought
that
it was important
that the public have access to this
trial
especially with
all of the media attention that it
received
now judge barnett said that cahill is
always willing to jump in
and chip in help out his colleagues when
necessary he did that when one of them
became ill
he's also a father and a husband
a father to adult children and
interestingly enough barnett said that
cahill is the person who interviewed him
when he was moving from the public
defender's office over to the county
prosecutor's office so they've known
each other for quite some time
brian that's fascinating i understand
judge cahill is also somewhat of a music
fan
yeah we thought we'd tell you you know
this is kind of a fun little fact about
him so during jury selection
some of the photographers who were
camped out outside the courthouse
apparently saw him
drive off and there was music blaring
and i asked about that
apparently he's a big fan of the rolling
stones ac dc
and ozzy osbourne so a big rock music
fan and apparently
uh when he was driving out one of those
days he gave the hang loose symbol
to a bunch of the photographers and
reporters so
i asked if he was kind of a cool guy and
judge barnett says he's not sure he
would describe himself cahill would
describe himself as a cool guy but
he definitely likes his rock music who
would have guessed terry austin you've
been watching this trial from the
beginning have you seen any clues
from judge cahill about how he might be
leaning or thinking about the case
brian i have not i do think judge cahill
however
is a cool guy and he's calm and he's
collected
he is the most even-handed judge i have
ever seen
he clearly has no tolerance for nonsense
so
when he sees one of the attorneys saying
something
that he's already ruled on he just
quickly says
i've ruled on that or overruled or
sustained he's very good about that
and he has not given any indications
of which side he is leaning on and so i
definitely think he's the right judge
for this case
i have no idea if he's for defense or
for prosecution and that is
exactly the way a judge is supposed to
be right
brian buckmeyer his most important
ruling probably so far has been the
addition
of that third degree murder charge which
seems it was almost
forced on him yeah i also would have to
echo what everyone is saying i'm sorry i
couldn't
hear the full question because of the
motorcycle in the background but
judge cahill is doing what every defense
attorney really wants
and that's giving them the ability to
try their case
i think he's coming across even kelter
and he's not really pushing
the thumb on the proverbial scales of
justice in any way shape or form
all right well thanks much coming up on
law on crime daily
why it took more than six months to find
crucial evidence in the george floyd
case
plus find out when the so-called
doomsday couple
cult will be in trial accused of
covering up the deaths of two children
and fleeing to hawaii to get married
the trial for the so-called doomsday
cult couple has been pushed back as
attorneys for the couple say they need
more time to prepare lori valo and her
husband
chad davil are facing charges for an
alleged plot to conceal and destroy
evidence while valo's children were
reported missing
authorities discovered the bodies of j.j
and tyler rayon
buried in shallow graves on daebel's
property
neither one of the day bells are
currently facing murder charges
and the judges ruled the couple be tried
together the date was scheduled for july
but it's now
looking like it won't happen until at
least the fall
i anticipate i don't think it's a
surprise to anyone that
a severance motion will probably be
coming down the line as well
in addition and i'm not going to address
this in detail today but
having gone through all of the discovery
that i've been provided at this point
i still have about 30 items on my list
that i need to
discuss with mr wood and miss smith in
terms of items that i'm going to need
them to provide me
all right uh mr means where are you in
terms of
preparedness for trial with your client
at this point
i think it would have to be vacated and
reset your honor does the state have any
objection to
the continuance requests no objection
no new trial date has been set but the
couple now has another hearing on the
motion to sever
and a change of venue in june terry
austin what do you make of chad davil's
defense saying they plan to file motions
to have
a separate trial separate from his wives
this is not the first time
chad dabell has signaled that he wants
to have a separate trial and i think it
means
he literally wants to be able to
separate his case
and his defense from glory and i think
we might believe that this means he is
going to point
the finger at her right now like he said
brian there is no murder charge we
simply have the destruction of evidence
and conspiracy to destroy
evidence and i think one of the things
we might ultimately hear
in his case if there is indeed a
separation of the cases
is that he had nothing to do with tiley
and jj
being buried on his property so much to
come there brian
a lot of attention in this case in fact
because of the supposed connection to a
cult
do you think it's likely the case could
be moved because of all the publicity
i don't think it's likely it's similar
to what we're covering here now in the
derek chovin trial
this case has gotten so much media
attention it begs the question
where could you go that there would not
be some sort of bias based on people
seeing
media reports or any kind of video i
think right where it is is probably the
best place
anyways you have a right to be tried by
jury of your peers i think it's going to
be hard for them to point
to a specific place where that bias may
not exist in this country
right well when we come back back into
the courtroom for the derek chovin trial
the surprising evidence found inside two
vehicles
well after chauvin was charged with the
murder of george floyd
investigators in the murder of george
floyd processed the police vehicle
and suv floyd was riding in in may of
last year
but it was not until december december
that the pills were found in the suv
i was told to collect suboxone
pills in the center console gum
if there was any gum present and
money and then also there was a request
to photograph some of the contents of
the
luggage in the trunk this is a close-up
of item 46
it was a suboxone packet that was opened
on the driver's side floor
and are you familiar generally with what
suboxone is um it is a prescription
medication used for adults with
an opioid addiction this is a close-up
of item 47
which was an unopened packet of suboxone
on the driver's seat
there were two pills in the center
console so were these
the pills that you were specifically
asked to retrieve from the vehicle
yes they were and then this january
defense attorneys asked for a
second search of the police squad car
and that's when they found the pills
in the back seat
when you began to process that vehicle
was it still
sealed up from the initial processing it
was not sealed up when it arrived at the
garage because that
because others had already been in to
look for this correct that was my
understanding
the pill is in the position it was on
may 27th the pill was
round in shape however it had a rough
textured appearance
to it and there were no visible markings
on
this particular pill did it appear
like it wasn't whole any longer yes i
think that's a fair statement yes
item 52 it was a small irregular shaped
piece that could have been a portion of
a pill item 54 you'll actually see two
item numbers for item 54
everything else that looked like it
could have possibly been a piece of a
pill
so the small remnants and the powder
that were remaining
i collected together from item 51
that the swab collected from that pill i
obtained a single source male dna
profile
that matches george floyd
so this raises some troubling questions
brian buckmeyer there couldn't be a more
high profile investigation supposedly
thorough what's going on here do you
think
yeah that it leaves you kind of
scratching your head as to how they
would be able to miss that
especially because of the first sweep
they were looking for
some illegal drugs and so it's not like
it wasn't on their radar
i think the defense has the ability to
drive that point home
and perhaps show that this investigation
was narrowly focused on one cause of
death and not trying to seek justice by
figuring out
if there are other alternative forms for
the cause of death and terry austin
there's also the question of whether did
this evidence suddenly
appear for some reason there are
questions about how cub
yes you know when we had special agent
james ryerson on the stand
prosecution was asking him questions and
he did focus on the fact that the
defense
asked you to go back and double check to
see
what else was there and it left the jury
i think with the question of are we
suggesting that
the defense put the pills in the squad
car because it was missed the first time
and then when they went back
those pills were located but i think
when nelson got up and did his
cross-examination of the special agent
he made it very clear that there was no
you know collusion or any sort of trying
to cover up or
plant any pills and i think that the
witness made it clear
nelson made it clear and in fact in my
opinion prosecution on
redirect made it clear so i think the
jury is not going to be confused by that
point
so brian buckmeyer at this point how is
the defense doing in trying to make
its case that the death of george floyd
was due to a drug overdose
i think it's very difficult especially
after dr tobin's testimony
where he basically outlined why this is
an issue i think his last line let me
google right to his last name which was
the most powerful one
where on the second redirect it was
asked of him by the attorney blackwell
but when someone dies from an overdose
of fentanyl they fall into a coma
right he answers yes and he asked
another question did george floyd
fall into a coma no so that kind of took
it off the table what i've been seeing
for most of this case is
eric nelson is able to bring us to a
point of reasonable doubt
uh after his cross-examination but then
the prosecution quickly pulls us back
into a place
where the points that eric nelson made
are not so reasonable when we hear it
clarified
a second time and quickly terry we agree
with that
i do i agree 100 i think both attorneys
are doing an
excellent job all right well thank you
all for joining us here on long crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we continue
to discuss the issue of
justice in america
[Music]
you